citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tara Erickson alongside Greg Alba
we are both a little sleepy I think I
forgot to brush my teeth but we're still
gonna watch Despicable Me 2. Despicable
Me 2. I love the first one it's so
fluffy it makes me want to die I've been
saying it since I've seen that movie I
just like run around town being like
it's not fluffy no one gets it nobody
gets it they just go wow look at her
maybe we should call security but I
haven't been kicked out anywhere not yet
ah white girls so guys don't forget when
you're watching this you gotta leave a
like you got a comment and they also got
to bring
good
ring the bell
and also if you haven't become a patron
you should sorry I had to have a heart
swallow there's a spit there you should
become a patron okay because if you get
over there you can watch the entire full
reaction of me and gray watching
Despicable Me 2 and you can sync up with
your own copy so you're sitting there
watching a movie and we're here too and
we watched the whole thing together
that's insane insane Greg and John also
cover several shows exclusively over
there with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included if there's no more
further Ado let's get into it
we'll do
[Music]
the Arctic is it Alaska or is it the
North Pole secret base Kristen wig is
back
so is Steve Benjamin Bratt
I didn't Russell Brand's the old
scientist guy nefario really yeah oh my
God I didn't know that
yes Arc Circle okay ooh the animation
already looks improved
oh no something magnetic is happening is
it aliens nothing aliens it's not a few
villain or something
or an alien no no it's a big magnet with
aliens in it take off all your metal
stuff
I would be on Belton right now and not
get off the jet ski whoa yeah you can't
whoa
holy junk
[Music]
Wilhelm scream that was a pretty cool
visual yeah that was pretty awesome did
look like an alien sucking up some
humans we don't know that it's not
aliens hey at least the porta potty
survived Ah that's like a Jurassic Park
callback kind of
oh this must be a game with the girls
[Music]
cool
oh he's such a sweetheart now
I love it
[Music]
it already seems like they're doing
cooler shots this time around a lot more
stopping shots so here come the gallon's
night to save us
oh my God I love it give me a Funko I
don't want a refund
please I'm begging you you gotta do it
buddy
[Music]
[Laughter]
getting for a kid's birthday
hey hey it looks believable
the most magical fairy
fairy of all
I am here
so cute
that's so bad my house is made of candy
and sometimes I eat instead of facing my
problems
okay time 4K
wow all that worked for lights yeah for
20 seconds
20 seconds of worth it
[Music]
I like literally can't even stand her
she's like perfect my friend Natalie has
recently single
and oh God it's you in the future it is
or me right now
oh
wow whoa
I wonder there's like fan theories on
what this creature is he kind of looks
like a boot that got brought to life
he looks like a rat terrier mixed with
like a porcupine ancient Lucy wild of
the AVL AVL
oh sorry
Advanced Aviation something or Advanced
villain like ah yeah
[Music]
he's flexible he and strong
you're gonna break his arm or his entire
body and crush his face I go get him
hurry up Steve Mark John Brian
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's always those kinds of trash cans
in these movies
[Music]
I'm liking the shots way more this time
around yeah
whoa
and that's inventive that's fun
oh boy no
[Music]
oh she is clever and capable she's
intense
oh my god do they get to go underwater
is this going to turn into a boat it's
so cool this one feels more spy movie
oh
it's totally a bond tribute is this a
spy leak I don't know
[Music]
this is awesome this is very like Bond
mission impossible-esque yeah way more
and I think they have a much bigger
variety of a color palette this time
yeah I was just gonna say it's so bright
and like really colorful I like it I
don't
I was like okay
our top secret lab disappeared from the
Arctic Circle the lab was devoted to
experiments involving px41 no no not on
the bunny
no no
oh
yeah eat them up good rabbit we've had
traces of it in the paradise mall and we
believe that one if these shoppers
God he's gonna be a spy but no no leave
me Father around and they legitimate
businessman I developing a line of
delicious gems and jellies
your work as a villain was kind of
amazing so if you ever want to get back
to doing something awesome
give us a call Wilde has a soft spot for
grown crew it's gonna have a love
interest this time
the minions be doing that yeah
[Music]
exactly what they were just doing
Joy
Lillian said she was arranging a date
for you she's in nut job and I'm not
going on any date and
I'm scared
oh here we go again oh my God hey Lisa I
was wondering
oh poor girl kids are evil well of how
these movies are about Gru overcoming
his childhood trauma yeah
all right his jelly business
[Music]
what's about to happen
oh
what was about to happen
oh okay
I thought you like all deformed
[Laughter]
I miss being evil I mean don't you think
there's more of our future up than
Shirley I've had an offer of employment
elsewhere what
there is no loyalty here traitor who's
he gonna work for oh maybe uh the magnet
oh that or orange jumpsuit guy is still
alive Vector yeah
hello
what just happened this time the aliens
are here
make my day it is the cupcake recipe I
got on the internet
colors are so much more vibrant and Lush
this time around yeah not the last one
looked good too but this one's more
striking
oh God that cupcake is terrifying the
shark is dope oh hello wild what are you
doing oh okay
what's the point of breaking them
mine just let them fall to the grill
she loves to find cupcakes why are you
here
but not me yeah but you're talented
that was a great cupcake Missy
out your cupcake
oh what does he love her oh my God
oh my God
[Music]
I feel your minion you're young and then
a girl smiles at you I get it
I'm gonna go on a date like that we're
just like shooting fireworks what
oh my God
Dave
I am Eduardo
owner of Salsa Salsa Restaurant across
the mall this is definitely the villain
right
yeah and I am going to need 200 of your
best golf guys decorated with the
Mexican flag it looks something like
this yeah
that's my future body right there I'm
going to assume that is Benjamin Brett
oh we've looked straight into your
future buddy and you are no good that
oh hell yes
get it
hahaha
oh why did they do a spin-off in this
world whoa he died in the most natural
way possible riding a shark yeah
oh my God this guy's awesome
volcano oh my God
yes oh my goodness they never found the
body oh no all that was ever retrieved
this is freaking wild it escalated that
guy
it's a great shot
yeah oh cool like zoom in yeah there's
way better like framing and lighting too
like the lighting in these shots is
crazy I guess there's more like style
yeah behind the way they frame it she
gets spreads
[Music]
trades others everywhere
huh let's try this one more time but the
things a bit less like a zombie okay she
kisses my bubbles
this is so sad you need to find a woman
for your children
oh no the aliens are back
oh take off your goggles
oh
what is that
oh there are no booby trunks
what have you Unleashed
ah
oh just a sweet little rooster don't be
fooled don't be fooled they'll claw your
eyes out some guard dogs
alien reference
[Music]
whoa all right Wild
foreign
[Music]
but hey maybe you can find something
with these x-ray goggles if you were a
spy Tara you would behave exactly like
this person
I would behave like wild yeah yeah
that adds up if someone were to ask me
like who do you know that is like agent
wild
straight up without pausing
ah
what is this sofa probably delicious
though
can you hear me
post that
I love that
stop
it's so dangerous
[Music]
oh these minions need a driving lesson
oh yeah bro oh yeah
[Music]
sign of a villain
oh my God I love me I love me so much
wait until the end to see if I like this
one more or not but so far it is cooler
yes I agree
[Music]
stack of money for ice cream
amazing why does this guy want the
minions I don't know
[Music]
the Zen crew would have a hard time
doing stop
oh
[Laughter]
that's great girls Lucy Lucy girls hello
hi
oh my god
oh the mom fantasy
oh she likes the daddy side Tara
[Music]
just stroke that ego
oh my God margot's fallen in love too oh
hey
whoa
cool glasses I'm Antonio oh is it the
son of him yes because the Z there's a z
on his shirt welcome
eagle
it's about time you showed up Mr gruel
okay
I think you need to move around wow this
looks interesting what is it
hold on I'm picking up something behind
that wall oh yeah this wig will
transform you from
ugly to irresistible don't get
distracted
too late
[Music]
did he grab the wig yeah
dream is to one day
oh my God
you're so complicated
complicated
that's great so good to see you again oh
I see you have already met my father oh
that's why I gave it all up Brew
discovered traces of the serum at Eagle
Hair Club sure but it's not please
I like this new world that they have
here a lot the direct Mission objective
I'm not as clear of a fan of anything
yeah I'm a little bit lost yeah I'm like
am I a little if I just a little
deprived or I am on the same page yeah
but I like dealing with the fatherly
qualities of him learning to be a yeah
not be overly Sheltering about the whole
thing
looks amazing
I want to go to there what is the father
of the minions
so we have like two villains
oh God
[Music]
oh my God that's right
irresistible hair I mean there's just
some
look like a serial killer yeah he looks
insane and so does she
hi no sure just a sec no don't catch it
no no I'm so sad for her right now
oh good she can't see Gru oh will she
recognize him with his hair yeah
well in no time that's offensive is this
woman voiced by one of the people who
plays the kids
are you wearing a wig no I'm gonna rip
that thing off your head and show
everyone what a bird
she is intense
nice
he's been shot with a mild moose
tranquilizer
[Music]
she no lag oh she's just uh
look
oh oh see see
oh my goodness
[Music]
I like how they're not villains this
time around but they still do cruel
things to people yeah this is their way
about a romantic night
surprisingly it was just between you and
me you look much better bald
see you tomorrow smart to keep the
childlike eyes and I really love the
idea of him having a love interest yeah
it works really well
watching how it's affecting his emotions
so much it's great he's happy he's
finding love
oh he's going to like yoga in the Park
good for him you know it's it's about
these movies like the gimmick of like
the thievery the villainy or the spy
stuff is the appeal to people but it's
like the most fun the stuff I love the
most is always like this stuff right the
softer stuff and everything I agree it's
empty but we found traces of the PX4 one
said a minute he's our man so somehow in
spite of your incompetence we solved
this one plant plant
get your Miss off of me
now you're all free to go back to
business and it looks like agent Wilde
will be transferred into our Australian
branch no I wanted to give you this your
lipstick taser yeah it's just a Memento
you're gonna remember me forever bye
grew
oh it's look out the environment she
says Vine it's all right it's darker
immediately
no guru don't go back to who you were
don't succumb to The Dark Knight of the
soul group
oh would you like
uh no uh
ah for real this time
to be yourself man oh come on that was a
real number I know it wasn't a 555 yeah
what's that about should we call it
later did it have all the numbers maybe
it was one letter one number missing
oh my goodness
[Music]
what is he doing oh my God
oh my God
oh my God that is my favorite
[Laughter]
also how have like Mark and Steve not
been like where are all the other
minions like how has no one been like
where are the other ones you can
distinguish them no no
he's always hanging out with Mark and
Steve and John and these guys have
cooler names the guys who are stolen
oh no they're you're gonna turn into a
giant purple minion
[Music]
yikes there are no rules
Come on they're starting man
[Applause]
[Music]
this kid is so hands on oh my God
sticking up on him so much
[Laughter]
this is a great visual motif foreign
sequels go this is a really great we are
survivors there's much more to us than
meets the eye enjoy the party
this makes me want Mexican food oh so
where did he just run to it makes me
want authentic Mexican food too yeah
Del Taco
Del Taco has better tacos than Taco Bell
because they have more it has more stuff
in it not everybody yell at me in the
comments
the secret lair you are so wrong about
the Taco Bell
they tastes so much better I don't even
need it anymore I love both but Dental
tacos tacos are like bigger and they
have more they have more cheese on top
oh no not the guacamole hat oh so sad
[Music]
you are gonna die somebody didn't take
music theory oh
nice
oh
would you like some peanuts or pretzels
all of it
my Ultimate Fantasy that is a good joke
she sees group everywhere she goes I
grew up
I would not want to travel with these
guys
I love that Action Hero thing if they
just do this that means I go faster
[Music]
evil magnet
where's his tattoo of the Mexico flag
right yeah it's time we shall Groove he
was working for him
job opportunity
absolutely oh that's why nefario is
kidnapping the minions
I had to borrow some of your minions but
it was foreign because that's horrible I
want him to go back and not be weird
geez oh wow
and here's the best part I got great
visual gags in this movie
[Music]
now he has to die
anyone tries to stop them
[Music]
together together
you must choose Gru
I'm not so convinced
oh no now evil minion is gonna go ruin
the party we need to go home now where
is Marvel
ous what is she heartbroken
he's dancing with someone else right now
hey wrong
oh yeah
poor Mario
yes nice he could really go to jail for
that have you
have you yes I take you somewhere around
here you two are close no oh I don't
know
oh no put it together
Lucy why did you say we're close did he
say that he never mentioned that you
were both working for the active villain
Nick uh-oh
well nefario
he knows you're working for the AV Hill
hey he's got your partner thank you
nefario both movies you thought he was
going to be bad but then he ends up
doing the right thing he's doing good
they kind of look like more advanced
stages of that one pet that Guru has
don't they oh yeah his rat terrier mixed
with a porcupine
I got what a creepy POV I did yeah
oh yep
oh God this makes me dizzy there's like
some semi horror touches in this episode
yeah movie I don't see any
[Music]
oh but Agnes could just like maybe
disarm him because she disarms the doggy
she'll be like David is that you
no the minions come out figure out how
to revert it back oh yeah
[Music]
oh that quick
what what the minions already had a
serum antidote
okay
finally put this horrible jelly to some
good use oh wow before then you put it
in all the salsa right it's like a
Shelly like I don't know the gel you
make it look salsa
okay don't be stupid minions
like just eat this also they all turn
back but like if the guy doesn't know
you're using it an antidote serum he
just thinks you're feeding them okay
that was my idea get out it was dumb but
for a moment in time we are not watching
Despicable Me 3D
masala
[Music]
that like twitching effect they got
don't get caught up in this man
uh oh
God
[Music]
ferocious little monster how are they
gonna they seem so much more formidable
as little villains than helpers they're
actually like a large quantities are
scary
oh
you just get to spray them oh nice oh
hell yeah all right nice
oh what a fun arcade game that's awesome
yes
oh
was that wrong no they're doing a great
job this is literally an arcadence yes
it is ever this is it see
is my spirit animal I think you're not
supposed to say that anymore but she has
my spirit
cool oh oh yes oh yes
[Music]
oh my God
look at that 3D it's coming right at me
he's over El Macho now where is Lucy is
that how much I like super strength
[Music]
Macho thing huh
one push of this button and I send that
rocket straight into the same volcano
where I faked my dad
nice tally ho
now
oh no
a macho Macho Man are they gonna play
that song now
dude he did not pick this through
dude nothing distro
[Music]
okay
Agnes scream you guys don't have more
jelly
oh the lipstick taser yeah
[Music]
nice wow did that really solve the
problem now go get some jelly off of the
wall and shove it in his mouth
oh he still has some left
no
[Music]
farts gun actually got to be used
against a villain nice
don't worry I will
oh no no chicken wants his revenge
oh boy there they go
[Music]
with what Society does to chickens this
chicken deserves to live
no all right
yeah good good good
no absolutely you guys are not eating
that shark you put him back in the ocean
we may not get out of this alive so I
need to ask you a question the do it
crew if I asked you out on the day
oh
[Music]
okay there goes that volcano
they make this disaster look so pretty
in the background
no no no okay good
oh yeah no there's just way more texture
to it everything wow doesn't that look
so pretty
oh yeah the other minions
oh they're still
that's a great callback
[Music]
they married wow that's so many dates
it's such a such a simple joke with them
it works it works
and his nose is huge yeah hey that curls
at the wedding mom
[Music]
I like to make some toast oh
Lucy is beyond compared oh
that's really sweet
wow I am see I I uh
you didn't even get a wedding outfit
nefario
his old date came to his wedding yeah
yeah I pointed that out earlier you did
pay attention this is why lo siento I
heard you say something but it was at
the wedding I didn't hear the name you
remember her name no okay it lives
there were two directors this time
around
uh well last time there were stuff
during the credits so we should now to
see maybe there is
sawing its way in from the 3D it's
coming right at me
[Music]
Cinematic Universe love it wow it's
coming right at me
[Music]
uh oh I don't like 3D most of the time
why does it make you feel sick it just
doesn't even just it makes the screen
look darker and it doesn't really come
at you
and then you get stuff like this like
this which is like where I'm like well I
don't have any of the effect desired
effect it's going for yeah
oh
you know what I like better than the 3D
is like the four matte whatever it's
called when they spray this stuff in the
air and your seat vibrates I might come
down with that
we could do that at Creed and I could
punch you in the boxing match
all of Greg's dreams coming true just
punching me in the face
hahaha
oh
hair and fur
[Music]
these little freaks
freaks adorable
the English best bee
oh no oh a boom blaster
[Music]
I do like the way this is escalated it's
pretty funny
minions
I mean that was pretty good I'm trying
you just you can't we got to do a whole
review I like this oh I cannot do it
I'm trying I can do it you have to do a
whole no oh it was not too bad
we have to do a full review
flight this
pretty good right everyone sold everyone
should annoyed the audience and try just
talk like that so they can't understand
we are saying I thought the movie it was
uh fun
and brighter colors and
I liked it I don't sound like the woman
had my laundry really they're dry
cleaners
oh he gets his suit done I'm gonna hide
my one suit he had to add in that he's
so important he has to wear suits and he
wears them so much he has to get them
clean when you're in your 30s it's good
to have a suit
when you're in your 30s these are Hot
Tips by Gregory Alba number one when you
hit your 30s get a suit get a suit and
if you can get a second
wow it's too much listen I liked this
movie and I didn't like it as much as
the first because the first one uh the
first one had more heart like the first
one movie cry at the end I really love
the speech that Agnes finally gives it
she worked on and then she finally gets
to give it to her now new mom but there
wasn't enough of a relationship built up
between them for me to like really
really care I was surprised that they
didn't towards the end
show just a quick Montage of dates but
also her being in the household with the
girls because I think even if it was
like an extra minute it would have made
me feel more during Agnes's speech if I
had seen some clips of her getting to
know the kids in a cute moment where
they're like they're kind of shy but
she's reading them books now and like
you know what I mean that was the thing
that popped in my head when she was
given that speech because I thought it
was so stinking adorable and I was like
oh how could they have actually made me
cry during that moment when I uh and I'm
like oh as if we if we saw more of the
relationship that maybe would that would
have made it too long of a movie
possibly but um
I still thought it was a lot of fun and
I'm glad nefario always comes back and
has their back yeah always always man
yeah always the repeat beat right there
yeah you know I I like the world a lot
in this movie and I think it Direction
Wise It's Slicker it everything pops a
lot more it's more vibrant they actually
have a lot of great Style with their
moving shots because I I remember with
the last movie like as I love the story
of the last movie and I remember saying
like the in surprisingly shot really
simple like there's a simple way of like
capturing everything even with the
animation there's there's a Simplicity
to it and here they take that Simplicity
but they add on more to it and they they
do a lot more with the visual gags a lot
of the way with the editing as well with
the reveals it there there was so much
more visually that I thought was
aesthetically more pleasing and then
overall too for a part two it's a pretty
solid sequel It's really fun and the
evolution of Gru with you know first one
is him overcoming
that sometimes you know Define love
you've got to overcome some of your
parental troubles yes right yes right
yeah right men yeah so you stop treating
women like crap get over your mom
problems or wherever you saw your dad
treat their mom and then maybe you could
find love inside the same thing with
women yeah or if your mom was a jerk
like you you know go to therapy for that
that's what I mean you gotta overcome
those things yeah so I actually like the
transgression of in the first movie it's
him getting over some of those parental
troubles and then this allows him to
open the door to finding love finding a
woman who is not like his mom who can
support him you know who likes him yes
bald head and his big nose who accepts
him for who he is it's good so there's
thematically I really like that a lot
even psychologically because it's really
they do have a psychological element
with Gru overcoming childhood traumas
right they didn't have
now that you say that they didn't have
any callbacks as I thought they would in
the first movie they did multiple
callbacks remember with his like Mom
when he was growing up or whatever in
the first movie they only did it that
one time where he was a kid in the yard
and yeah that maybe could have bened
benefited this movie if they had just
showed it a couple more times like they
played with it in the first of him
having like an afraid moment before he
even asks her like I mean it could have
even been a funny callback of like he's
on the rocket and being like he's gonna
ask her but there's a he has a moment
where we go into his head when he was a
kid and he was rejected I think I would
have liked seeing that yeah I would have
liked it too I do think that this movie
is certainly creative and it's there are
a lot of inventive ways they did a lot
of the the entire execution there's a
lot of event of things on screen I do
think the actual story is
a little bit more by the numbers for
this genre of what it is of like there
was something that was more unique I
thought with the first movie and I'm not
just even talking about the introduction
of the world it's the the way the story
plays out with like this ridiculous
thing of trying to
steal the moon and then you know finding
the love with the daughters and there's
a unique tale of a guy who
uses these children and ends up being
like no I actually love you it's it's a
much more unique story for sure and it's
all it's weirder but it's I thought more
touching and then here it's a little bit
more straightforward yeah yeah like they
follow the tropes of like what we would
see in an anti-villain like um whatever
we're gonna fight him down we gotta
figure it out like Yeah The Love Story
too yeah well I liked it I thought it
was charming and I like I think Lucy and
Gru are uh there's they're really
adorable and I think uh imagine I wonder
if Kristen Wiig and Steve Carell were in
the same booth together recording
because they do have great chemistry
um and other things they've worked on
too yeah yeah I agree yeah I also am
still very concerned about was that
Mexican tattoo of the flag was that so
it wasn't a tattoo it was like it was
drawn on and then it just came off
because I'm like that is weird
continuity that I was thinking about so
much that when they he finally admitted
that he was the villain and there was
that big magnet that I was like he's
gonna come out and be like and this is
my evil brother who was distracting you
with the tattoo on it yeah so I'm like
where did that go that that was that was
honestly that bugged me for a minute I
understand and I think his necklace
moved a little bit because the reason I
said yeah that's his son because he had
a z on his shirt because his thing had
an M it's for M for Macho but in some
shots in the beginning it looked like it
was rotated to a z that's so that's why
I said that okay I also another thing I
I like the sorry what's the name of that
girl who was into the sun
into the sun the girl who was in who's
into the villain's son
oh Margot Margot yeah
I like the inclusion of that story I
don't feel like there was much of a wrap
up or a lesson really learn others it
just ended with her being like boys suck
when it was when it was one of their
many B stories you're right about that
because that's what probably led us well
for sure leading us to going like he
might be the real villain and he's gonna
get to Margot and the kids and then it's
gonna blow up where they have to go save
the kids or something yeah but that just
ended up being kind of a
a non-fulfilling Beast story of like
yeah this kid's a jerk because his dad's
a jerk too I know there was like in the
middle of all the cacophony of stuff at
the same time I feel like that did lend
its open that could have opened a door
for some kind of emotional beat for Drew
to have yeah and some of those emotional
beats with the children were sort of
missing here so that's I actually get
where you're coming from when it came to
that speech at the end yeah because
there wasn't much of the bonding that we
saw and it was just like oh they just
want a mom instead of seeing the
relationship form of Lucy which would
have I think behooved the movie to and I
think both these movies are at their
best yeah when they're doing that stuff
yes
they are the things maybe it's
I don't know maybe for the kids I don't
know I don't know what the kids think
it's like maybe the kids like those the
other spy stuff more and and we as
adults like the more emotional stuff
more like if it's standing reason but
imagine now that I'm thinking in my head
it would have been a perfect spot where
Margo is sat at Salsa and salsa but
Margo uh sorry uh what's the love
interest name Lucy yeah Lucy but Lucy
shows up and is able to give her a talk
about like not like a full-on attack
about boys but gives her some sort of
sentiment some sort of like sure yeah
you know what like you're right she like
picks her up and then Margo's like ah
forget about it uh maybe not totally but
she teaches her something and maybe we
have a moment where Lucy teaches yeah
maybe one of the girls a little
something that they take that they
haven't that you kind of just cannot get
from their dad yeah from a male figure
right that would have been really nice
and taken what 20 seconds with each kid
if there was a way to add it in there so
yeah I agree I feel like we're missing
that but I also don't think if they
added it in that it would be a boring
thing for the kids to watch because I'm
like the only reason they got to
Despicable Me too is because one was
freaking great you know I mean I still
think though the you know sequel to
Despicable Me could have easily just
been as I've heard some people not
really praise some of the other ones
that much okay mind we'll see how they
are yeah
um but I still feel like for a follow-up
it's it's really hard to do a follow-up
to these kind of movies they usually are
just repetitive or they get more
childish and here I thought they at
least they really made a concerted
effort to enhance I think some people
maybe like this one more I actually and
I saw comments of people saying like
vector's the best villain in the
franchise oh I personally preferred this
yeah over over Vector yeah vector vector
I didn't we weren't the biggest fans of
actor yeah I didn't like dislike him
just didn't really leave it in person
was like yeah it was whatever and then
here there's more of an I feel like I'm
gonna remember this one more
I think so too like his it's like he has
more of a larger broader character and
maybe it was like because we also
weren't only introduced to him as a
villain right off the bat he had he was
just a regular person with a regular
like oh get me these cupcakes and join
us at this party and here's my kid and
blah blah blah versus with Vector we
didn't really have that we knew right
away it was just like he's a bad guy but
we had to figure it out with Macho macho
man yeah interesting setting how most of
this was just at a mall it's really
interesting guys there there is like
some Easter egg thing when that you've
our very first seeing them all when you
look up there is a Disney like d in
there and I'm like this is DreamWorks
right or it's elimination it's unit
illumination but anyway and then it was
never there again but I swear to you if
you go and you look and it's the little
Disney like maybe saying hi to him I
don't know odd you know yeah it's a
whole thing anyway I mean I liked it
[Music]
I'll give it like a 6.5 because I didn't
get the emotions out and the first one
really did that with me yeah
um I I probably I'm actually I really
really admired it's so funny usually in
these situations on this channel I'm
usually the one a little bit lower than
everyone else but I'm actually I'd
probably be like seven yeah probably
like a 7.5 because I thought the
directing and the cinematography and the
animation they really amp that up they
really in a way that just kept me kept
my eyes glued to the screen was because
of that yeah I thought they just they
added so much personality and flourish
to that that that was weirdly the thing
that was kind of missing for me from the
first movie and and I thought they
really brought that here so just due to
that like I'd still give the first one
like an 8.5 yeah oh me too
for sure because of the story yeah
exactly yeah we're here I would be like
I I would get point I got to give it
points for the seven point like for what
they did because yeah I I do think that
um they introduced a neat World here
with the anti-villain league but they
didn't really explore it they were kind
of doing a lot in this movie there was a
little it became a little it became a
little convoluted to me yeah I was like
we're both unclear about what the
mission is what is the exact objective
here like they're trying to locate the
guy with the magnet right but I feel
like have we lost sight of that yeah but
they think the guy the the wrestler I
forget his name uh Macho Macho my God
that's such an easy name
the guy with the magnet right is that
what we're getting at uh
I think I get it but I feel like I'm
also not 100 sure yeah uh but nah man
overall I still want to see Despicable
Me uh whatever and then we'll see how it
goes
shout out today proper I'm gonna watch
you do it I'm gonna watch you do it it's
me Tara and this is great and we were
watching Despicable Me 2 and we hope
that you like
tell us if you want us to watch three we
love you goodbye
illumination
banana
foreign